remember one of my test pilot friends
was was really feeling sick but did not
want to go to the doctor because you
know want to be grounded he finally
couldn't take it he collapsed on the way
to the doctor's office this is not a
good idea kids if you're sick go see the
doctor I'm Mike Massimino and this is
how health is different in space I was
an astronaut for 18 years
I flew in space two times two missions
on the space shuttle health is really
important for astronauts there are a
whole list of things that can have you
become disqualified from going to space
typically you want to try to be as
healthy as you can and you want to have
a healthy heart you want to be as fit as
you possibly can you want to eat right
and take care of yourself and if you
don't and you fall out of the standards
that you're supposed to be within it
could mean you're not gonna get a chance
to fly in space
you don't have to be an Olympic athlete
but they want to make sure that you're
healthy enough to do the job which means
they don't want to be worried about a
medical situation when you're in space
if you have a propensity toward kidney
stones for example that was a
disqualifying thing they don't want you
having a kidney stone develop while
you're in space a medical situation on
earth is bad enough but in space it's
really bad so they want to make sure
that people that are putting into space
are not going to have a problem once
they're in space
exercise is important for all of us
before I became an astronaut I generally
did sports for recreation and riding my
bike for fun or maybe going for a run
things like that once I became an
astronaut it became a little more
structured I felt like I was getting
ready for somewhat of an athletic event
because space walking did require
exertion and you needed to move around
almost constantly and you had to
manipulate this suit that you were
wearing so the better shape you could be
in the better off you were gonna perform
I was in the best physical shape of my
life before each one of my space flights
and that was I was older I was 39 on my
first flight then in 46 on my second
flight but I was in better shape than I
ever was as a high school athlete or any
other time in my life exercise in space
is a little bit different because you're
in zero gravity you're floating so it's
it's as if you're on bed rest but even
worse than that as far as physical
conditioning goes you're laying around
you're not exerting yourself you're just
floating around and even doing things
like just walking or even sitting on
earth you're fighting against gravity in
space you're floating the whole time so
it's no load on your bones or on your
muscles and if you don't exercise in
space for a prolonged period of time you
can lose bone mass and you can lose
muscle mass and your heart which is a
muscle it'll shrink and that's not a
good thing so the way we prevent these
bad things from happening is by
exercising
weights aren't going to work very well
in space you can take an object that
weighs 600 pounds and pick it up with
one finger because everything's floating
this weightless so you want to be
pulling against something for a
resistive exercise work out like a
spring or something that has some
resistance to it was that works just
fine in space but actual weights won't
there is a two-hour exercise period set
up six days a week for astronauts who
are on the space station and it's a
combination of cardio which is riding an
exercise bike or treadmill the seevis
the bike cycle ergometer vibration
isolation system the vibration isolation
part of it is pretty important when
you're working out you can cause
vibration and the advantage that you
have on a space station for science is
that you're in zero gravity and if you
start shaking and vibrating that
compromises the microgravity environment
you're going to disturb the experiments
that are using the the microgravity of
the zero-gravity environment for the
science but start shaking it up a little
bit you're going to hear about it so
these engineers who have developed these
machines plug don't get as much credit
as they deserve because they are not
only keeping astronauts healthy but
they're isolating the vibrations
associated with doing that sort of work
out to those machines and not spreading
it around to compromise the integrity of
the zero-gravity experiments onboard but
that's the way you can get cardio
exercise in space for a resistive
exercise advanced resistive exercise
device a red which is a pretty high-tech
piece of equipment that works on pulleys
and Springs and and you can do a variety
of exercises with that you could even do
squats you can do leg presses you can do
curls you can do bench press and so
combining that with the cardio devices
you get a pretty good workout we also
had Thera bands these elastic bands that
we would use they give you some
resistance and we have astronauts coming
back in sometimes better shape than they
were when they left
the way we prevent sickness and space is
by putting you the astronaut into a
quarantine ahead of time so you're not
bringing germs to space so spacecraft
should be perfectly clean there's there
should not be bacteria in the spacecraft
so what we do is we enter a quarantine
period not a week before the flight in
your what we call it is health
stabilization the only people that are
allowed to be around you have to be
screened and approved by the flight
surgeon there was an age limit that
changed for kids to be around you my
first flight my children were too young
to be near me my second flight they were
both teenagers so they were able to come
visit me food poisoning is probably not
gonna be happen because that's all
control the what goes on board your
water is clean water if I think we could
treat it as well with iodine if needed
iodine leaves a certain taste so there
was a another filtration system we had
to remove the iodine out of the water so
they really want to make sure you water
was clean so you're in a pretty much a
germ-free environment
on earth when you're not feeling well
you can go to the doctor you have
somebody try might take care of it
yourself in some ways it's some medicine
or aspirin or whatever you have
available to you but eventually if
you're feeling sick you can you can go
to doctor and get checked when you apply
to be an astronaut if you if you get far
enough along in the selection process
that you're a finalist and typically
there's about a hundred hundred and
twenty finalists for each astronaut
class and then they'll pick however many
they need your selection interview is
not just an interview but it's also a
lot of medical exams and you get checked
out pretty much from top to bottom it's
a really extensive medical exam that you
go through that takes a few days and
they'll check you out and make sure that
you're you're healthy I still go for an
annual physical every year as part of
like a long-range health data collection
that NASA does but in space your medical
care is a little bit different we had a
full set of medicine in our medical kit
for just about every kind of ailment
imaginable and we had to make sure we
didn't have any allergic reactions to
those medicines so we got a drug testing
kit we were supposed to take one of
these they would tell you how many is
supposed to take in every day pretty
much we tested something different where
there's an antibiotic or sleep medicine
or a painkiller or whatever it was we
always had someone who is our main
medical officer on the flight sometimes
that was a doctor I never flew with an
MD I did fly would have it in a
veterinarian and he became a medical
doctor but someone needs to work on that
person as well so they have another
person who is kind of like the assistant
so you always have at least two or
sometimes three people who were trained
to be medical officers we get CPR
training we get basic first-aid so we
can help each other that way but some of
us get the more extensive medical
officer training which is kind of like
the equivalent to being an EMT you also
are in close contact with the flight
surgeon so flight surgeons are medical
doctors who have the special
certification that allows them to deal
with aviation space medical issues are
flight surgeons also aware of things
can happen in zero gravity and the ill
effects of zero gravity them in bone
loss and muscle loss in other issues
that might arise because of the
spacesuit causing of injuries and so on
for the job we have so if you have a
problem in space there is a first-aid
kit there's a medical kit that you can
do basic things with you can do things
like suture open cut if needed surgery
is a bit of a problem I think at first
in the space station program they
thought that they would be able to do
surgeries it really is not practical to
be able to do any major invasive
operation if someone needed something
like that they would do orbit them and
bring them home it's easier to do that
take care of that on earth that's not
going to be the case when we go further
away from the planet we're going to be
happy to you can't fly people back from
Mars that easily you're gonna have to be
able to deal with things and on route or
once you get to that new place so right
now the luxury of being close to the
ground helps with a lot of major medical
limits we've never had anything that
we've had to do that for we've never had
to do or 'but for a medical issue if you
need help from the ground on the space
station on the space shuttle we were
able to call the ground and and see if
there was a there was help
motion sickness happens to most people
it happened to me in my first day in
space I didn't feel very well it's a
it's a conflict between our vestibular
system and/or eyesight that conflict can
lead to a little bit of stomach
awareness you're moving around the cabin
let's say with your eyes but your
interviewers telling you you're
perfectly still and it does not feel
good I was not used to it my first day
in space of course and I ended up
throwing up at the end of the day then
the next day I was flying and on my
second flight I was fine you brain
doesn't know what's going on at first
and it reacts a certain way but then it
learns and you don't have a problem so
it's an adaptation as opposed to a real
sickness how do you throw up if you get
sick in space who the sun's starting to
come up so here's an astronaut barf bag
right here puking works just like it
does on earth and that stuff will come
out of your mouth right from your
stomach like a projectile now the
difference is that if you do that on
earth it's probably going to land
somewhere in space it's gonna come out
and float around which is not a good
situation they'll get everybody sick so
we want to use our vomit bag we have
really good vomit bags emesis bags is
what they call I guess emesis is a fancy
word for vomit you had vomit into those
and it they're really well made they're
cloth on the outside plastic on the
inside so everything will go inside of
this bag and then once you're done you
can seal it off
rolling up compact it and get another
one ready I was very concerned about
this in my first flight I had two on me
all the time that that first day my
after the first day I was fine I didn't
need one but you want them handy when
you first get to space
I think in everyday life we realized the
importance of mental health and trying
to keep ourselves mentally healthy and
NASA is the same way
so it was always help available if you
needed to speak to someone about
whatever issue you might be having and
they were very open to that it was just
like anything else if you had a if you
were sick you went to go see the doctor
and if you weren't feeling well and felt
that you needed to speak to a mental
health professional that was available
for you as well and you were expected to
go see one if you weren't feeling well
so they were very open to that and it
was very important and and I appreciated
that I think most of us did in space I
think what NASA has realized over the
years in particular for long-duration
flights or even short flights there
could be some extra mental stressors put
on the astronauts it could be stressful
you're worried about your your physical
well-being so there's stress associated
with that also performance of your job
you want to do a good job and you might
feel the pressure that way to also
you're away from home you might not get
as much sleep as you like it's a new
environment there may be family issues
happening all these things might be
happening that could also affect your
performance we have a whole program
associated with what we call
psychological support and psychological
support is there to help astronauts feel
good and that all involves contact with
home so we have email we have a
capability of calling or our family and
friends from space through an Internet
Protocol phone the possibility to Skype
with your family is there as well
keeping in contact with earth is really
important for psychological support it's
not just being nice but it's also - for
performance a happy crew member is a
productive crew member what I've seen
come though sometimes is that a an event
happens on earth we had a crew on board
space station when we had the Columbia
accident and
we needed to get the word up to those
guys that we had this accident in and
the crew was lost then the accident was
a time where mental health was really
stressed in fact it was required that
all of us go check in with the
psychiatrist when a traumatic event like
that happens like a loss of life
bad news happened on earth for directly
affecting the personal life of the crew
member in space that's when you
sometimes need some psychological
support right so I think that comes in
different forms sometimes it's a crew
member a good friend
remember the clergy a spouse a brother
whoever they try to get that person on
the phone
so then your flight is over and you
return to earth so once you come back
and you land the biggest difference that
you'll notice is gravity is kicked back
in those changes to your body that
occurred because you went to zero
gravity and some of those are physical
changes they're revert back to the way
it was when gravity is encountered again
so some of the physical changes for
example is in space our spine grows of
it because if our spine is held into
place by gravity to some extent and in
zero gravity the spinal long gates so my
space walking suit was actually sized an
inch and a half higher in the waist to
accommodate spinal growth than what I
was ordered the space I would wear when
I practiced in the pool for my
spacewalks if you get a little bit of
discomfort in the back when that happens
in space you feel it a little back pain
but then it goes away when you come back
to earth your spine is settling again
immediately so you have to be really
careful no abrupt movements with your
head we've had some astronauts hurt
their backs particularly in their neck
by doing something a quick motion or
something like this before things have
settled can can hurt themselves I mean
I'm supposed to pick up anything your
kids are usually the biggest hazard
because you want to hold them and pick
them up if they're a baby that's not a
problem if they're a teenager they're
too big to do that but you know
somewhere in between you know you want
to be careful with that so lifting
things as soon as you get back are an
issue because you want your spine to
kind of settle where it's supposed to
and the other thing that is a physical
change is the fluid in your body in in
space when you're in zero gravity tends
to pool in your upper extremities what
that could mean is when you get back to
earth in gravity sets in and the fluid
redistributes you could get lightheaded
your blood pressure you go down you
could pass out so one of the things we
do to help prevent against that before
we enter we go through fluid loading
where before you enter we have a lots of
drink bags and as a prescription you get
based on your body weight of what are
you supposed to drink it could be salt
tablets with water or is chicken
consomme or there was this thing we
called astral aid
which was kind of like a not really
Gatorade but he had to drink a lot to
try to get those bodily fluids there so
that when you got back to one gravity
you didn't have this bigger orthostatic
problem when you tried to stand up
bigger issue maybe or the thing that's
more prominent is what's going on in
your head because now gravity is there
again and that vestibular system that
was silent for all those days or however
long you were in space is now excited
again and it's getting input like crazy
in the brain saying what's there like
what the heck is that's what's going on
here you want to move slowly I felt like
I needed to walk with my legs wide apart
because I feel like I was going to fall
over to keep my balance and they want to
turn my head very much to excite the
minus stimulus system as much and after
a couple days gyro you're fine but
you're instructed not to drive a car or
a flying airplane or lift anything heavy
or do anything like that until you're
approved for those activities by the
flight surgeon final farewells and
handshakes all the way around before
they make their way through that hatch
way behind peek into the soyuz tma 19 m
spacecraft
one of our biggest concerns for
astronaut health in space is radiation
exposure we have to be careful about
that here on earth as well we're out in
the Sun we want to wear a sunscreen
protect us from the harmful effects of
the Sun in space we don't have an
atmosphere or a magnetic field which
also protects us from radiation here on
earth if you're above that you're going
to be exposed and that we're very
concerned with so we try to do whatever
we can to shield the astronauts from
radiation and we do that in the
spacecraft for example by using certain
materials and shielding that will
protect them from radiation NASA does
monitor that we have a device called the
dosimeter which is a wireless looks like
a piece of plastic that can measure the
amount of radiation you have taken and
it is placed in your in your launch suit
and then you hand that in at the end of
the mission and they read it to see how
much radiation you've been exposed to as
we go further and further away we get
further from earth radiation exposure
could be the most important issue that
needs to be solved or prevented against
if we're going to be travelling further
and further into space something we
don't always think about radiation
exposures is it can be very harmful and
it's a real challenge for space travel
[Music]
one thing remembers you want to enter
your space flight in his best shape as
possible it's hard to make up for a lack
of exercise while you're in space but it
is much easier to be able to maintain
where you are and maybe get a little
better if you enter the flight if you
launch in pretty good physical condition
for now the best way to stay healthy in
a zero-gravity environment is to
exercise